how you doing AJ I'm doing well we've
had quite a last couple weeks so I I'm
living a good life right now
you sure are dozen wins in a row a
perfect tenant Oh road trip I mean how
how do how do you manage such a
situation right what's your approach
here yeah you know it was an interesting
road trip because we we went to Texas
which is always you know no matter what
the records are it's always you know an
interesting series and our rivalry
series and we won in a couple different
ways and then headed out to the west
coast and won some games and then ended
up in Kansas City where was extremely
hot and just kept winning games you know
in different fashions we won late we won
early we had tremendous starting
pitching we also had a bullpen that had
been you know scuffling a little bit
that bounced back and did well so you
know you kind of played a complete
baseball and you expect to win and then
when we got home we did lose a close
game to the Tampa Bay Rays and then
responded with factor back-to-back home
runs to beat the Rays and win this
series so you know when we're operating
the way we are and we're playing you
know pretty well in all facets pretty
talented team and we feel pretty
confident and Altuve is leading the
league in in average he also is on base
percentages is is 401 I mean so four out
of every time ten times he goes to the
plate you watch and he's on base what's
your favorite Altuve story the defending
MVP got one for me yeah well my first
year with them you know he was the first
player that I met when I became a
manager he was in town when I flew in
for my press conference and I sat down
with them and and and so I immediately
got to know him pretty well and you go
through the 2015 season and that's a you
know a few years ago but that was our
coming-out party when it comes to the
Astros this young talent the arrival of
Korea Lance McCullers jr. came up you
know Jose Altuve was starting to get a
little bit more national recognition and
you know Jose's always been you know
gifted was just filling up the same
everyday
playing hard and Bullock to tea with his
level and never once a day often and so
we go through 2015 season here's a
remarkable season he ends up having a
really tough series against Kansas City
Royals and we got beat out in the AL
Division Series is the first time we've
been to playoff that over a decade
that's an organization so it it meant a
lot to a lot of people I think it
probably meant the most to Jose Altuve
because he had he had never been on a
winning team in the big leagues he had
been the face of a rebuild that was you
know largely unpopular around the game
and so he comes into my office after
after game five and broke down in tears
and he was upset and he was so
disappointed himself because he only got
two hits in the division series and he
apologized to me right before I went out
and addressed our team at that end of
the season sort of manager coach
opportunity to address your team and
right then and there you realize what
winning means to Jose and how he was
going to take all the the bullets so to
speak when you lose it you lose a series
and I and all I told him was he you
aren't the reason that we lost you're
the reason that we got here and and it
showed a lot of character out of Hosea
that the most vulnerable time he was he
was going to take all the heat even
though he he was largely regionally were
there well I mean I love bringing him up
for many reasons with you here AJ
because obviously baseball is such a
human game it's all about heart it's all
about courage it's all about achievement
when people think that you don't have
the physical attributes to do that and
then it's also about numbers analytics
and you are at the forefront you're at
the cross section of both of these
things here is the defending Super Mario
series manager what does it look like on
your desk with all sorts of numbers and
how do you take all that in before a
game and and and use it in real time can
you I'd love to tell you I'd love to
tell you and continue to joke that you
know my dry erase board is full of
mathematical equations and my my desk is
full of spreadsheet and and we have a
little bit of that but we have a pretty
good blend of of how to apply the
analytic everybody has the same
information you know doctor how old
school you are or how traditional you
are the information is there for you
you know we just feel like we're pretty
good at applying it you know as fast as
possible with some of the best players
in organ so you know my my desk which
looks about the same I mean we we've
done such a good job of having all the
information and then deciphering it and
and what I've learned in my time is some
players can play and what kind of
information some players can't the
secret I think is being able to apply it
to your players to get the most out of
it it's not about being the smartest or
having the most or or kind of be in the
you know the most bizarre or even on the
progressive side you've got to figure
out you know just like in a cooking
recipe how much how much of a sprinkle
of this the tablespoon of that a full
dose of this and and the players respond
accordingly so I can see that my dad's I
guess is you know some sort of
mathematical equation out of a movie so
what about resting players AJ I know
you've been talking about that a lot you
and the Dodgers are two teams that
played into November last year
Altuve the only one who's played every
game so far have you applied any sort of
numbers and abut what's the trick to
that in your mind we have obviously it's
different physical bodies to me I've got
George Springer who's is you know could
be playing on Sundays if he if he wanted
to and that big physical strong athlete
and runs into walls runs into people
like he has one one speed and so I pay
attention to him a little bit you know I
always got to be cautious of his lower
extremity his legs his much you know
like how his hamstrings house quads are
doing Carlos Correa had a little bit of
a scare with an oblique issues that he
missed a few games Alex Bregman you know
is it is a terrific young player who you
know I've got to just force it day off
on it and in Jose I gave him a day off
the other day until the ninth inning
with the game on the line I I had a
pitch hit so you know we do pay
attention we played to November we've
gotten the Dodgers the Alexi teams I've
been pretty pretty forward with our our
players they're not going to play 162
games I know old school and back in the
day and the Cal Ripken streak and all
that stuff that that we just feel like
we can physically get these guys in a
better place the second half will be
nice to us
with it with some days off with a new
collective bargaining agreement but no
doubt we have to pay attention to to be
good you know ironically the day after
hosea gets most of the day off he goes
you know eat twice and past three hits
and looks fresh as ever so we have to
remember these desert human AJ Hinch
here on the Rich Eisen show from your
perspective manager and also the
position you played when you played in
Major League Baseball but seeing the
pitching staff the way that is
performing what can you compare it to
anything that you've seen before AJ you
know I remember the Phillies you know
back in the in when they won the World
Series and they had you know kind of
rolling out a lot of different you know
Cole Hamels quickly boy on those days
they were just really really deep I
remember the Braves growing up I was a
big Braves fan I get to watch them on TV
all the time
you know the Maddox most Glavine I mean
it when you're throwing a starting a
really good starting pitcher every
single day it puts a ton of pressure on
the other dugout they just know they've
got their work cut out for our team
knows if we get to lead you know we ever
we have a really good starting pitcher
that's probably going to go you know
seven innings which in today's world is
is is pretty deep into a game it's it's
nice to have that that group and they
feed off of one another for lenders that
zone Cole has been a tremendous addition
Charlie Morton's probably is quiet of a
guy to have a great season you know
Keiko and McCullers who are leading this
staff over the last couple of years you
know are certainly a great way to round
out you know the rotation I don't care
which guys starting in the giving day I
have complete confidence that we're
going to get these into the game that
fits the six to seven that have a chance
to win well and the few minutes I have
left with you AJ Hinch of the Astros
here I'd love to bounce off you a theory
that I've been throwing out here because
I'm just not a I'm not a fan of all
these strikeouts you know obviously that
line football Durham they're they're
what they're boring they're fascist or
et cetera et cetera
there's not enough baseball's being put
into play for my liking and part of the
reason I think it's it is existing is
because of the
a shift that too many guys are trying to
hit it over the shift best they can and
you employ the shift just as much as
anybody else what what if there was a
rule to get rid of the shift would you
have a problem with that
I would I don't think I would I wouldn't
like it I mean I our sport you know to
give it a different analogy for you as
our you know it's not supposed to be a
layup drill so you have to you have to
play to the defense that they're playing
it in football if they're playing man
coverage and it's bump and run hitters
they're up in your face you can't say
hey I'm allowed to have a five-yard
start in basketball you know you can you
can double-team people and baseball we
can we can suppress offense because of
the way we the way we position our
players but what's what's different
about that that analysis I don't you
know we still give up half the field
whenever whenever someone's hitting so I
I would encourage the hitters to make an
adjustment more than I would try to
create an even more boring sport that
you're just you're just going to stand
in these positions where the grass is
going to die underneath your feet and
we're we're just gonna play this vanilla
style baseball I don't think that would
be support that well I mean just as a
fan as well we're on the subject if I
may engage you know I don't want to pay
just for an instance to watch Bryce
Harper bunt down the left-field line or
go the other way I want to see him leave
the yard best he can obviously you're
you're paid as a manager to make sure he
does not wither however way you can you
know and baseball's also the only sport
where the defense holds the ball already
it just seems to me you know it's it's
too much of a bizarre look and an
advantage AJ sure well well I would say
this you know we said you want to see
Bryce Harper hit the ball out of the
ballpark
I'm defending against the error when he
doesn't and so I think that playing the
shift is really the error he's trying to
borrow out of the ballpark the fact that
he comes over the top of the ball and he
hits the ball on the ground to the right
side of the infield doesn't mean he
should be allowed to hit because he made
a mistake that's two different ways he
can beat me one with it if he does make
contact hit the ball the ball parts to
appease the fan and and the other is if
he rolls over makes a mistake he's
supposed to have his open gaping holes
where his mistakes are going to be
that's what you did why don't you tell
him to hit the ball of the ballpark to
left field that's the same home run you
can watch him try
trot trot around and the entire field is
open to them that's it that's the
cat-and-mouse game that's the chess
match if players don't if they don't
want a sindelle if they don't want to
base it am I saying fine I'm saying
manipulate the barrel enough to be a
complete player then then they have to
deal with the consequences so then I
guess this might be an odd question to
ask the manager who whose team possesses
the best team er a and batting average
against right now if you could change a
rule to make offense a little bit more
prevalent in the game today what do you
think would be the most fair application
of a new rule AJ Hinch I think that
might be something that they could look
like I don't know if that would increase
offense you know I think I think I think
we have to start training our players to
be offensive players and not you know
sort of the all or nothing
approached it that that's being
compensated in our pack I think we have
to if we're going to change offense I
think we have to train better we have to
we have to play the game better we have
to we maybe maybe we have to deter
strikeouts by the compensation package
maybe contact is more important than
then then simply you know the the beer
league softball or nothing approach so
do you sometimes look at exit velocity
for real like you as a manager from from
bat speed and things like that do you
really parse it don't worry no I'm aware
of it I don't I don't really pay a ton
of tangerine I still use my eyes I know
when a ball to heart you know I know the
ball out of the ballpark or judge or or
George Springer rifles a ball in the
right-center like ice I know you know
you can tell me it's a hundred 110 under
15 I just know it's hard a jade love the
way you go about your business and
always love our chats appreciate the
call maybe we'll just catch in
Washington DC for the all-star okay and
then down the road or two you got it got
it
you bet that's AJ Hinch his Astra's take
on the Kansas City Royals tonight the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience